reden wir über gute vorsätze gibt es
irgendetwas was du möglicherweise noch
nicht über den haufen geworfen ausgibt
sollte auch wer gerne zuhause normen
nichts vorgenommen weiter machen wie
bisher wenn wir in dieser standort
holten standard halten das ist finde ich
schon da kann man sich genug auf die
schulter klopfen bloß nicht jetzt zum
glück ganz viele bild zuschauer
deutlich ambitionierter unterwegs sind
für 2022 die sich richtig gute vorsätze
gesetzt haben und auch zumindest jetzt
am fünften jahr nur noch guten dinge
sind die auch einzuhalten die ziele
tatsächlich zu erreichen das ist ja
große bild aktion wir helfen ihnen dabei
unser spar volksbank ochse macht genau
dass er hilft ihnen beim einhalten
dieser tollen großen neuen vorsätze
fragen sagt noch einmal bis mitternacht
konnte man sich bewerben mit den
tollsten größten besten guten vorsätzen
und du hilfst genau ich mit meinem team
wir helfen wir haben sehr viele
zusendungen bekommen wir sichten das
jetzt gerade noch mal und wir wollen
natürlich auch dass wir unterschiedliche
menschen helfen also nicht nur auch
aufräumen waren riesenthema man wirklich
sagen aber dass wir da sehr
unterschiedlich das auch zum beispiel
der ganz normale zuschauer leser auch
was davon hat vielleicht der sich nicht
beteiligt hat an der aktion aber
trotzdem was lernen das sagt man strom
jetzt halte ich durch und wir haben
jetzt noch eine weitere zuschauerin die
hat sich auch bei uns beworben und die
wir ein bisschen mehr ps in ihr leben
bringen wir schauen mal rein in ihrem
beitrag
wird meine damen dass christine
eisenbrand ich habe mir für das jahr
2022 vorgenommen dass ich endlich den
führerschein machen möchte ich habe
schon zwei anläufe hinter mir und müsste
das jetzt gern dieses jahr über die
bühne bringen und hinter mich bringen
meine kinder würden sich auch sehr
darüber freuen weil sie auch als mal hin
und her gefahren werden möchten zu den
freunden oder zum fußball oder so
deswegen wäre es schon schön das jetzt
klappen würde ich habe jetzt eine
erkrankung hinter mir und da habe ich
mir dann auch vorgenommen dass wenn ich
gut überstanden habe das endlich machen
möchte das finde ich super und das ist
absolut auch machbar frau eisenbrand ich
grüße sie hat sich hier bei bild live
toll dass sie sich das vorgenommen haben
darf ich trotzdem noch einmal in die
dunkle vergangenheit ganz kurz schauen
was es schief gelaufen bisher sie haben
es zweimal haben sie glaube ich gerade
gesagt schon versucht ja genau ich hatte
bereits mit 18 jahren meinen ersten
anlauf gestartet
damals kam ich immer abends relativ spät
nach hause nach einer ausbildung dann
war es mir abends dann immer ein
bisschen spät in die fahrschule
irgendwann hatte ich dann irgendwie
keine lust mehr dann war ich einfach
abends platt und müde wenn ich von der
arbeit kam und habe ich das schaffe ich
am vorabend noch nicht mehr dann hatte
ich nach ein paar jahren das noch mal
probiert in einer ferienfahrt schule
aber da kam ich irgendwie mit dem
fahrlehrer nicht so gut parat und dann
hat mich irgendwie der mut erst mal
verlassen und ich muss ehrlich sagen die
letzten jahre habe ich den führerschein
dann auch nirgendwo mehr gebraucht ich
bin auch mit kind und kegel bisher
überall hingekommen wo ich hinwollte mit
bus und bahn
von daher ja gut ich weiß halt wie
gesagt erkrankt und
hat den tumor und ich habe mir dann so
ein paar sachen vorgenommen wenn ich die
erkrankung hinter mir habe dass ich das
irgendwie noch in angriff nehmen möchte
einen vorsatz oder eine sache die ich
erledigen wollte habe ich letztes jahr
schon erledigt zwei sachen fehlen mir
jetzt hat noch
auf diesen weg wollen wir sie begleiten
wollen wir sie nicht alleine lassen und
deswegen ist jetzt fahrlehrer thomas
würden uns zugeschaltet und er kann
ihnen jetzt schon ein paar tipps geben
wie es dieses mal im dritten anlauf dann
auch wirklich klappt mit dem
führerschein herr würden
guten tag jetzt mal
schönen guten tag wie schwierig ist es
denn wenn man jetzt schon ein paar
anläufe hinter sich hatte und jetzt
nicht mehr ganz punkt genau 18 jahre alt
ist ja den tisch zu bekommen
also grundsätzlich
gibt es kein alter wo man sagen kann man
dürfte keinen führerschein machen ja
also ich hatte jetzt einen herren der
hat mit 30 jahren noch mal den führung
so was ja
generell ist natürlich klar wie bei
allen sachen umso älter als bisschen
schwerer tut man sich mit der sage ja
aber ich sag mal autofahren ist eine
reine lehre sache und das bekommen die
dame mit sicherheit weil man darf sich
nicht entmutigen lassen auch wenn man
vielleicht mal negatives erlebnis habe
das sollte kein problem sein
also ich bin mir ganz sicher dass sich
vor eisenbrand nicht entmutigen lässt
sie hat sich das mutig vorgenommen
nachdem sie ihre krankheit besiegt hat
während sie kinder großzieht also das
sind nun wirklich die größeren aufgaben
als mal ganz schlapp den führerschein zu
machen frank jetzt sind wir mitten im
spiel das heißt da bleiben wir jetzt
dran bei frau eisenbrand das knapp 20 22
mit dem führerschein der frau eisenbrand
wir haben uns wirklich lange gedanken
gemacht und wir fanden ihre geschichte
wirklich toll und natürlich zwei mal
versucht und wann dritten mal muss es ja
wirklich einfach klappen also wir sind
der meinung wir unterstützen sie dabei
wenn sie demnächst ihren führerschein
haben dann bekommen sie von uns 1000
euro belohnung also wir setzen uns für
sie ein brauchen sie noch motivation
dann haben wir unseren fahrlehrer herrn
würden vielleicht oder noch weitere
tipps ich kenne mich auch noch ein
bisschen aus mitfahren also wir geben
jetzt alles damit sie endlich ihren
führerschein bekommen was sagen sie
super vielen dank das freut mich sehr
wir haben nämlich tatsächlich an
neuwagen bestellt wenn man hat
eigentlich ein dienstauto dass er auch
privat nutzen darf und unser bestelltes
auto soll eigentlich ende januar anfang
februar kommen wenn alles gut läuft mit
corona jetzt da fragen wir das doch ein
die hier wirklich herr würden sagt
bestimmt auch mit stolz wenn es noch
motivation bedarf dann bin ich auch
dabei und so schaffen wir das
wir drücken die daumen
viele erklang danke dass sie mitmachen
bei unserer aktion wir helfen ihnen ihre
vorsätze fürs neue jahr auch wirklich
umzusetzen
und vielen dank dass sie dabei sind mit
viel ps geht's also dann in das neue
leben in das neue jahr